I never expected you to come. I have enough monsters.
After I buy them, I have to check the strength of my rival. It's a strange coincidence.
I was thinking the same thing.
Government
Ignis
Axel Is it
huge?
Breath of the Blue Dragon. I
see, it's a good monster. Your dragon too.
If you're just hiding your power, then let's just
burn it down.
[Music]
Holy Gathering
Did you manage to get through it with damage reduction and the power of the government? I guess you
wanted to see the attack, but I
can't give away that much information
from the beginning.  Don't think that he had no intention of defeating me or that he would
return me safely,
as long as he could do it.